here magnus with the white pieces game
will start and this was the situation
yesterday as well david
was a must-win situation for hikaru um
what will he have learned from that yeah
he will have learned that if he does get
a small chance to be aggressive he has
to seize it
and that's why nakamura already on after
move one nakamura spent a minute and a
half there
just thinking because he was trying to
come up with an idea for black that
would throw magnus
and in this position white has options
what can push a pawn in the center the
move i personally like especially in
blitz and rapid chess is to actually
move the knight on the left-hand side
and okay he does push forward with the
pawn
and okay immediately the tension in the
center has been eliminated
but the tension is still on the board it
just transfers
over to the sides the reason i like this
position though is it's actually
the same opening as a line of the
english
uh opening with colors reversed white
has one extra tempo however
and that's why i think it's quite a good
opening for white so right now white can
play bishop
move over plays bishop takes knight but
okay magnus plays a very positional move
and the whole motif of this
little move is actually to prevent
black's light square bishop
developing and pinning the knight
against the queen
magnus just weighing up the risks now he
might develop a knight might develop a
rook
might just take that pawn off and might
even capture that knight on the left
side of the board
but we'll see yeah we'll see and he he's
chosen the most solid approach and that
is just capturing the pawn
just as david recommended so he does in
fact capture with the pawn
i think capturing with the rook was
maybe playing a little bit with fire
and okay magnus now developing but i do
agree
a lot yeah magnus surprised by that
decision i think it's
not because it's a bad move by nakamura
but just because it's a move which shows
actually he's not taking risks nakamura
he's in a must-win situation
but he's not taking risks you mentioned
ivanka black could have taken with the
rook
and i think that would have been a more
dynamic way to play is it still
ambitious by hikaru
yes he's uh definitely taking some risks
he's just improving his queen there we
see in
nakamura's face he kind of made a
type of face and um okay meanwhile
magnus does
re-root the white bishop that bishop
wants to step one square back
attacking black central pawn both sides
have isolated pawns in the middle
and it is about who can target the
opponent's weak pawn first
[ __ ] not really looking too happy
with his position but he's doing the
right thing he has
taken some risks at least okay i like
what magnus carson's last move
we do notice a lot of pressure on this
pawn is eyed up by white's knight
and white's bishop that's why black had
to retreat his knight to this square and
now magnus
bringing his queen forward attacking
this knight the knight can't move
otherwise the central pawn would be lost
that's why nakamura plays a move he
would have hated to play
especially in a must-win situation he
has to retreat the other knight
back to where it came from back to its
start square to protect its fellow here
and
the reason the computer hates black is
simply the passivity of these two nights
they're both stuck
both of them have to stay where they are
defending things uh
meanwhile though what nakamura will be
positive about is that maybe later on he
can start pushing
some pawns against the white king if
things get desperate that will be his
last chance
to start pushing pawns meanwhile magnus
going forward with his queen
trying to attack this pawn nakamura
defends it it's all about this central
pawn right now
if magnus can break through and win it
magnus will simply win the game he'll
coast to victory
but nakamura defending it for now and
getting ready later on to launch
counter-attack yeah i was about to say a
few moments ago i although the computer
likes white i don't think it's winning i
don't think it's that much
um i think it's a small advantage for
now but two or three moves it could
completely change
um so nakamura definitely i'm not
writing him off i think he's got decent
chances i like how he's been fighting
over these last few moves
he's kind of been clinging on keeping
the tension that last pawn push
stopping white's idea of bringing the
bishop to that left side also creating a
an idea of black's bishop jumping out to
attack the white queen
and not just attacking the the white
queen
trapping it too david so uh there is
a big threat in the position and this is
something that always sets the heart
the heart rate uh pulsing up and down
and you can see that is the big threat
and
the queen doesn't have too many squares
if magnus allows that move
unfortunately you sure it's trapped
though ivanka if i just move the rook
like maybe i can hide out here you're
hiding from it's not nice
but it's not a nice square but uh it is
a safe square for now
but the knight can even jump forward
into black's half and we do see
this position on the board now the white
queen hasn't been kicked back
but nakamura he needs to find a backup
plan so that one he needs to find a
follow-up at least
um i like how he's been handling the
board and the clock but this rook needs
to join the action
okay he doesn't use that rook he uses
the other rook mysterious
mysterious stuff and i'm surprised he
didn't utilize this piece
but now at least he has some pressure
along this line nakamura trying his best
at least to fight
one thing i'm still struggling to
understand is why the computer favors
white so much
i mean white's position is fine it's
harmonious everything's protected but
it gives white such a big advantage i
think it's to do with that night that
really bad night that's next to the
black king
i mean what's it doing nothing true so i
think on that basis
one bad piece makes a bad position
exactly and
the computer's just saying you're not
gonna get that one out
um okay magnus does drop the bishop back
offering a trade of rooks
that's very safe and a good tip for
everyone just
bishops long range pieces they're okay
at the back rank it's more important to
make sure the rest of your pieces aren't
blocked in and magnus happy to initiate
one set of trades
with the rooks and now surely it's time
to
move the knight in front of the
remaining white rook open up the white
rook
improve that night yeah suddenly the
more i look at it white's piece is there
unravelling
and he didn't move the knight to the
square that i wanted it to i
kind of wanted it to go to the right but
okay he's gone to the left
and uh now looking at the black
center pawn although that is not
humphries not under attack
just yet but still some nice squares for
it to go to so hikaru
well he retreats his bishop and it seems
to me that he's just
just trying to find some moves perhaps
trying to cause magnus to panic a little
bit
with the threat or the dream of
attacking on the right side so if
there's no strategic ideas for black if
there's no way to
assert your strategic dominance you have
to go dynamic you have to play on the
front foot
he does retreat his queen however still
biding his time
maybe creating a square for the black
rook to use but yeah it does feel like
nakamura
slowly is running out of opportunities
to complicate this one
um white queen has stepped back and the
black bishop has improved itself
um that black bishop looks a bit shaky
though ivanka on an open line and that's
why
white does line up his queen and the
white rook the black bishop stepping
back
only one set of rooks have left the
board only two pawns have left the board
there's still plenty of
ammunition left for black to create an
attack later
magnus i don't know how he found the top
computer suggestion that it wasn't even
on my radar
bringing the white queen all the way
over to the other side lining up the
queen with the bishop using a bit of
teamwork
along the light square diagonal but um
still
white lacking an immediate plan nakamura
waiting
biding his time for the right moment and
okay
four minutes versus eight minutes
anything's still possible
uh i liked your idea your rank of
pushing a pawn that pole might have been
doomed but at least you block it up you
gain a bit of time
uh you get a few moves at least and uh
okay a trade has happened and white's
bishop
jumped forward and nakamura okay now he
is
making his intentions clear he's pushing
pawns finally on that right-hand side
just scare at least planting the thought
of a kingside attack in magnus's mind
he's trying to scare magnus but magnus
not flinching retreating the white
knight
there's a threat in the position the
square that the knight was previously on
has been vacated and white's bishop now
wants to jump out there attacking
black's rook pinning that rook to the
black queen
hikari did step back with the rook and
magnus
now re-rooting his knight
and luka hikaru who carried it says you
want to go to that square i'm not
allowing that night there at all wow so
magnus is actually
won a pawn um we were so busy looking at
the right side of the board we forgot
that black was hanging upon on that left
side so
although white has had to give up a
bishop for a night a fair trade
um to win that pawn it looks like uh
white's remaining pawn now on that left
side it will
cause a distraction a serious
distraction for nakamura
and uh white's magnus is
just uh really working that solid angle
he's not letting hikaru do anything okay
so hikaru
advances his pawns and uh definitely
there
is the threat of an attack and hikar
well magnus attacks the queen but okay
is there some chances now for some sort
of tricks the queen can step back
the queen was most likely will step back
um
black could if he's feeling ambitious uh
just counter attack against white's
queen there with his rook but the queen
does
eventually step back and um i don't
really see the immediate threat for
black i do like what black's done he's
activated the diagonal
of his dark squared bishop i was uh
maybe saying that that was an issue with
black's position just a few moves ago
but black starts with bishop
yeah okay so icaru has gone from my palm
desperate times desperate measures okay
so the black knight
re-roots itself and the whole aim is
that the knight is going to come forward
and try
to cause some mischief in the center so
i mean the big
test of this is just simply can white
capture the pawn and just say i'm gonna
be two pawns up i think the answer is
yes
you can be greedy take a second pawn why
not um if we just
bring up okay we don't need to bring up
the analysis board because magnus just
moves
if he had captured that pawn i think he
was fine magnus carson but black would
have gained some time
by attacking the black queen so magnus
not being greedy jumping forward
back with his knight to where it came
from actually um
now just daring nakamura to play bishop
takes knight
ruining the white pawn structure but um
actually just removing a potential
attacker
that black bishop was doing quite a good
job putting some pressure on white's
position so
magnus is saying you can trade but i'm
getting closer to the draw if you do
that
and maybe black needs to do that um
nakamura now
debating whether there's an option do
you have to take that night ivanka that
has just moved
yeah i mean unfortunately i would i
would love to say
no but uh it's so dangerous that knight
is going to come into the center it's
threatening a pawn and that's a key pawn
so
um unfortunately magnus
is playing amazing chess and
it is hikaru the one who is in deep deep
trouble
and if this were a normal game it would
be hikaru who would be doing
everything possible for the draw and uh
what would you do david would you
capture the night
reluctantly i think so with a heavy
heart um there's just nothing else
for nakamura to do and i don't think we
can fault either players uh
in this game magnus he's played perfect
chess solid chess
not taking too many risks knackers
played great chess as well creative
trying to make things happen but
it's just so hard as black if your
opponent's in a solid mood especially
when you're opponent to the world
champion
and nakamura he's trying and he'll
continue taking those risks because the
draw
is useless at this point but yup he's
running out of
opportunity to do that he's running out
of pieces as well if bishop takes knight
right now
and the time advantage is getting very
low
he's disappeared pretty much already and
yep he has traded the bishop for the
night
and now pushed his knight to about a
square
burst okay david's very ruthless
[Laughter]
and okay nakamura playing a defensive
move nakamura offers a draw
with that move and magnus accepts magnus
wins the tournament
magnus carlsen is the winner of the new
in chess classic the first tournament
he wins in the multiwater champions
chess tour and there he logs up all
right
he took us a little bit there but there
we have the reaction huge
congratulations
thank you